hey I'm Claire soffits and I'm Brad
Leone from bone Appetit and today we're
here and we're gonna be doing Shep's
support question number one the one
kitchen gadget I will never get is a
food dehydrator why is that a thing
well because it's good at the hydrating
food and if you wanted the hydrating
food I mean I know a lot of ovens make
dehydrating settings but I mean without
if you wanted to make jerky or different
little fruit leathers or Scobie snacks
and you want a dehydrator
well not all ovens have oh that low like
some ovens bottomed out at 150 200 and
sometimes you need a lower temperature
to really dry something out fruit
leather that kind of thing it's like if
you're into food crafting maybe it's
worth the investment if not yeah and I
understand it's a big bulky thing to put
on the on the counter but some of them
are even collapsible I mean that seems
like the least of anyone's problems next
question okay does anybody know how to
make kombucha tastes a little better the
taste isn't too bad and I kind of like
it but the aftertaste fits me there's a
lot of complexities and layers to what
could be behind all flavors of your
kombucha maybe it's the tea you're using
maybe you have some funky yeasts and
bacteria in your atmosphere that are
giving off all flavors maybe you're
fermenting it too long and you add like
fruit juices and purees right yeah so I
mean if you're doing right out of the
container the first fermentation right
off the scoby people drink it there and
it's quite nice it could be a little
weird but I like to put it into a bottle
and then hit it with a little bit of
fruit juice and let that do a secondary
fermentation at room temperature maybe
that's where you can pick up a little
bit more of a pleasant flavor I'm fed up
with useless garlic crushing gadgets
that split chunks out the side oh yeah
big chunks out the side I'm considering
getting a fine microplane grater top I
mean I would say definitely get a
microplane regardless of your garlic
needs because it's so useful like
grating nutmeg also do citrus zest yeah
it's an indispensable kitchen tool when
it comes to garlic like if you're trying
to make Mayo or an aioli and you need
like a garlic puree
yes microplane basically liquefies it
but if there's some cases where if
you're brown and garlic and a pan like
you want pieces clark to hard wants to
know
how does one bake bread without an oven
there's only really one option that's to
make like flatbread that you griddle
unless you somehow like had a cold
situation outside with a Dutch oven you
like put the Dutch oven in the coals put
the comb over and you create your own
oven some flatbread is the answer next
customer why is fermenting vegetables so
much easier than pickling vegetables
this is a serious question
fermentation seems to be a bit more
difficult process but in my experience
it's much easier to do successfully I
disagree with her I think there's so
many more factors and variables that can
change and and throw you off in
fermentation it's easy to make things
rot to do it in a controlled rot which I
call fermentation it could be a little
trickier pickling is a little bit more
you have your recipe you have your stuff
you add it and it's kind of set it and
forget it so yeah I mean if you're in a
time pinch a quick pickle for onions is
super quick okay so we just add a little
bit of water to this here pan little
vinegar a little salt and sugar you
really just want the salt in the sugar
to dissolve and then you have a little
jar like so with some onions in it or
carrots or whatever you're into and then
you just pour that right over
wham-o Bama I mean you can let that sit
for an hour too but really you know
twelve hours overnight is fantastic
where it'll really start to penetrate
the vegetable that you're quick pickling
and all those colors will start to bleed
nicely and those flavors kind of marry
well okay subete friends when it says
range 1 to 4 hours WTH what the hell oh
how do you decide this is an example of
a sous-vide machine so you put this in
your pot of water and it's a circulator
maintains a temperature when it says
cooking range 1 to 4 hours that gives
you the window where you know you can
pull off very similar textures you go
past four hours you start committing it
might start to change the texture of
whatever you're cooking but it's usually
that that kind of holding window do a
little small batch and find you know a
little tests you know and see what batch
see what time you like the most
alright where do you buy top-quality me
make me personally
do you shop for it at the grocery store
or go to a butcher shop ok ok have it I
would always recommend going to a small
you know book
shop where you can meet the people you
can find out and talk to them you can
you know see where their products are
coming from and there's just you know
there's traceability and accountability
for each product yeah we're down in
Central Texas in the hill country who
they were dealing bison and chickens and
you know and seeing how they treat them
they loved those animals and the animals
were happy they took them twice as long
to harvest them because they didn't have
they weren't pumping them full of stuff
like grain to fatten them up quicker
when you let it do its natural course
you get a healthier meat you're gonna
healthier products and you know it's a
more ethical way of consuming news
considering getting a blender to make
smoothies in is it worth it better than
the food processor we already have yes
good even tools a food processor creates
comedic chops basically creates small
bits and you can let it go and it will
make it it'll make a thing the blender
it liquefies weird a little side-by-side
yeah it's why in the Vitamix yeah it's
not really a fair fight oh Claire its
Barry the Vitamix versus oh yeah it's
for the sake of science clay so it
especially if you're using ice the the
lender will crush the ice and much
better than food processor when with the
blender you got to add a little liquid
usually to get it going which is fine
because it usually wants that is the
advantage of the food processor is you
don't have to there does have to be like
a critical amount of liquid for the
start ready yeah ready
oh no dad they'll have turbo
yeah sure yeah here's looks like hell
looks like bear scat oh I like to put a
little mint in there look at that
chunky Cheers Claire here's looks great
have fun picking that I owe to you oh
well visually she has a lot more chunks
and bits going on
I'm sure face fines it's not to the
texture no mine's got that nice kind of
bounce to it have a little yours yeah
here dump that swell out focus player
okay I'll take this fun when baking
cakes
sometimes you fold in and sometimes you
beat in the ingredients how do I know
when to fold and gonna need feeding
folding is reserved for the operations
that need to be done gently to like keep
the volume in the mixtures and feeding
is the make sense you want to vigorously
combine two things cloud board I'm
multiplying the recipe by 1.5 the
original recipe calls for one and a
quarter sticks of butter how much should
I use my brain hairs I get more flour
that's right one and a half batch is
converting into tablespoons Porter six
butter so a stick is eight tablespoons
plus a quarter 10 days so plus five
tablespoons is use 15 tablespoons right
done yeah make you an expert all right
what do you think about baking with
Greek yogurt love it great idea
say like substituting oil for Greek
yogurt that might not work out but I
love baking with yogurt and other
acidulated dairy like sour cream because
it adds a lot of tenderness to it makes
good like a cake pound cake that kind of
thing so it's doing a lot but it's I
would not recommend substituting it for
the pad can't do it in the recipe
midnight Bananas Foster is great but
does the fire part really have to burn
off all the alcohol I think what Kyle's
really asking is do you have to flambé
you can just pour booze on it and eat it
that's I mean at all its puff paint you
can cook off the alcohol without having
a flambe
right the flambe is just the drama its
but like yes I think you need to cook it
because otherwise alcohol burn gets in
the way of all the other flavors okay so
we're gonna do a little flambé demo yeah
we'll turn this up and would you say we
have a little sugar in here brown sugar
butter and cinnamon crumb dippin on
trend up and done here's your banana
hats no man you're just Asian applause
chef love your eyelashes what was the
question
you gotta burn off your booze yeah how
is he gonna shuffle um I think for a
proper Bananas Foster
you have to flaunt it you have to yeah
today's baking status enthusiastic
unskilled seriously how do I get the
icing to stay on the cake they're taking
this one's simple one absolutely make
sure the cake is fully cooled because
even a little bit of heat from the
center of the cake will melt I think the
mixer run off but if you're going for
that look of like the really defined
beautiful light drips
you need a much thicker glaze I would
hold back the liquid by half
beerus fermenting vigorously it blew the
air logoff exclamation point how do you
get dried liquid marks off your wall
beer is fermenting vigorously but it
shouldn't really blow the lids off
especially if you had the airlock it
must have just been doing so so so much
that the amount getting out wasn't
enough so I had a kitchen to miss half
recently we had an exploding can of
sweetened condensed milk then determine
the dulce de leche did I tell you the
story no I didn't explode you leave it
on the stovetop I didn't leave it on the
stovetop but it happened and we had
little ellipses shaped with marks fun
every single wall of our entire living
room and kitchen and the ceiling you
might have to paint the ceiling because
that's what we had to do really this
like
imprecise recipes exactly how of Jesus
exactly how thick is a quote thick
Savion for visual indicators like this
or if this thick YouTube is a great
resource do a little searching on
YouTube for like sabe oh how to make
something on you can see it so we're
gonna show you really quick how to make
the fix that me on what that means so
this doesn't have too many ingredients
when he got there we go to light him in
both color and texture okay so that
looks good I think so you can see take
the second to dissolve okay so that's
ribbon alright now you know that's right
so this is a double boiler is very
gently simmering water underneath you
don't want the water to be boiling
because you don't want it to over keep
the bowl and the idea is that this
becomes like voluminous at all triple at
least in volume and you will see the
ribbon again yeah I'd say that is a 6mm
ribbon puts the back of the spoon volume
oh it's got cookies Claire I'll read it
to you I can never get my macaroons
right help please what did I do wrong so
these have what they call a foot if you
go to like a fancy macaron shop you'll
notice that little ruffled edge on the
bottom so that's hard to achieve so they
have the foot but the tops are uneven
and cracked a little bit so that to me
says that you're over beating the batter
it's like you're working too much air
into it mmm and then you're not folding
enough after you're adding almond flour
which depletes so it shouldn't split
like that no it should be a really
smooth non shiny like matte finish so
try beating more after you incorporate
the almond flour to take out some there
give it a nice tap on the counter a
couple times to bring out any big air
bubbles then let it dry out on the
yeah for you know 20 minutes and you can
go longer so you develop the skin and
then that'll help you get a really
smooth surface you're not the foot so
you're doing pretty well
okay ovens don't cook food people cook
food what's the best tool for cooking
food ovens don't cook food well yes they
do and people also cook food
it's a symbiotic relationship BB
business people cook food what's the
best tool for cooking food people now
then but then does it make sense
Claire you solved the riddle all right
Rachel McCain wants to know can I have
duty the science of reducing a sauce
before you yeah I got room or something
yeah because even if you add like a
cornstarch slurry or something or like a
pheromone yay to a sauce if the sauce is
watery the thickener will thicken it but
it's not gonna make the flame I'm still
gonna have to reduce it to the right
amount right next question when making
chocolate mousse to use egg whites or
whipping cream a decision must be made
this is a good question the problem with
using just whipping cream is that it
will it will actually fall like right
it's not stable so the idea of adding
egg whites and chocolate like you're
creating this sort of stable mixture
that in the fridge is maintaining as
keeping that air so I would say go egg
whites or both don't only don't just use
whipping cream those miso paste go bad I
have everything to try this but the miso
paste is over a year old with no gates
prints up no now you'll be fine I have
one that's been sitting out at room
temperature for about two years now and
it just gets denser it just gets more
like chocolaty and firmer I think the
rule of thumb for like if something bad
is it's not fine does it look fine if so
it's probably fine all right
Cal Wilson wants to know how does one
poach in olive oil now strong won't
isn't that just a fancy way of saying
deep-fry this out of it no
absolutely now poach is usually just
submerged and low and gentle not fry the
hell out of it poaching is like no color
you're not trying to put color on it
poaching is your crispy edges the
opposite fry right let's move on Oman oh
dear but cavity
there's Brad do all of his own stunts
does he need a body double my husband is
available it's your doppelganger he's
better way better looking than I am and
yeah please email me a resume and we'll
consider it I do all my own stunts thank
you all right we answered a lot of
questions yeah ton of questions and a
lot of them we're good you know people
really put thought into it and care
about what they're cooking and I like
that people were asking questions it
means are cooking at home and trying new
things and experimenting right and you
learn more from the failures than the
successes the only way you do it it's
like just keep just keep cooking keep
making mistakes and we'll help you
figure them out